[Música]
y hoy en revista de prensa nuestra
periodista rosa pérez más de eeuu nos
hace un repaso por varios de las
noticias más importantes de américa
latina así de rosa buenos días como ésta
buenos dias maria clara muy bien gracias
y tu muy bien gracias entonces
comenzamos en chile porque el presidente
gabriel boric tiene que hacer un
reajuste de su gabinete luego de que
perdieron en el plebiscito con el
apruebo y ganó el rechazo comencemos
como está reportando esto dínamo bien
maría clara pues un poco la prensa
chilena ballena como dices de este
cambio de gabinete que es un movimiento
bastante recurrente por parte de los
ejecutivos cuando hay una muestra clara
de desaprobación o de que el gobierno
está en ciertos problemas bien dínamo
señala que fue uno de los momentos más
difíciles en palabras del propio
presidente que ha enfrentado en política
el presidente dice dinamo dejó ir a
personalidades fundamentales de su
círculo cercano como vemos en la imagen
al destacada en la que tenemos a boris
despidiendo a la ministra de interior ya
saliente ex ministra de interior y es
que a sitges por otro lado también
récord moritz que los grandes cambios no
se hacen de la noche a la mañana y que
precisan de grandes mayorías un poco un
discurso reconociendo no la derrota o
los motivos de esta derrota en el
plebiscito de esta derrota de la prueba
recordemos y también acaba con una cita
del presidente diciendo estos procesos
siempre tienen retrocesos cuando quien
quiera que sea se asume como vanguardia
y pretende ir más o demasiado rápido
impactante esa foto ross ahora cuéntenos
cómo lo registra el desconcierto bien
otra de las cosas que ya tenemos no un
nuevo movimiento es la reunión en la
moneda de los líderes de la derecha con
el presidente gabriel boric y
precisamente así lo titula el
desconcierto la derecha pide un cambio
de foco al gobierno frente al nuevo
proceso constituyente y es que
recordemos hay una un cierto consenso
entre la derecha el centro y la
izquierda para llevar adelante un nuevo
proceso constituyente no pues como
decíamos un consenso de las fuerzas
políticas chilenas exceptuando la
extrema derecha del partido republicano
de jose antonio kast en todo caso lo que
le piden al según la prensa chilena
favoritos los líderes de la derecha es
que cambie un poco el foco de sus
políticas que le reprochan estado muy
centrado durante estos meses en el
proceso constituyente y entre otras
cosas que se enfoque en temas que
preocupan realmente a la ciudadanía
según ellos como la seguridad y eso ya
lo denotó el discurso de boris cuando
anunció este cambio de gabinete y por
otro lado que le piden que la
preparación de este nuevo proceso
constituyente quede más bien en manos
del congreso ya veremos entonces si se
produce este cambio de foco y también el
consenso y cuéntenos la tercera que dice
precisamente en relación a esto que
comentábamos no la tercera dice que los
presidentes del centroderecha advierten
al presidente que debe tener sentido de
la realidad y entender que tiene minoría
en el senado y en la cámara de diputados
y que debe primar el diálogo para
avanzar y es que precisamente no si el
congreso se encarga de este nuevo
proceso constituyente hay un cambio en
el equilibrio de fuerzas y es que las
sensibilidades del oficialismo estaban
más podemos decir en la asamblea
constituyente de lo que lo están en el
congreso no vamos a ver cómo se acaba
resolviendo esta pues este posible nuevo
proceso constituyente rosaura cambiamos
de noticia como lo registramos en las
noticias en nuestro noticiero estaba
avanzando la investigación por el
intento de asesinato contra la
vicepresidenta argentina cristina
fernández de kirchner pero en la prensa
argentina que se está diciendo empecemos
por página/12 hay también consenso en
las imágenes que abre la prensa
argentina y son estas fotografías de el
celular de la pareja de fernando sabaté
montiel prenda uliarte en que vemos a
ambos con una pistola y con balas lo que
según los investigadores da indicios de
que el ataque contra la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner habría
estado preparado no hay digamos
distintos ejes en esta investigación que
como bien dices va avanzando por un lado
el rol de la pareja del atacante como
comentabas en el noticiero brenda
uliarte quien ya está bajo custodia
policial que según las investigaciones
junto al atacante no a fernando se va
montiel en el lugar de los hechos en ese
mismo momento y también días previos y
mintió en televisión cuando dijo que no
había visto a su pareja desde hacía días
y que tampoco sabía nada del arma otro
de los interrogantes es hay más personas
implicadas en este ataque
página/12 dice que no se trata de una
gran organización sino de un grupo
marginal con una ideología que mezcla
antikirchnerismo antiperonismo racismo y
neo nazismo y que se investigan sin
embargo los vínculos con organizaciones
de extrema derecha digamos más
estructuradas que han protagonizado
algunos de los escraches más agresivos
contra el oficialismo y hagamos un breve
repaso por qué dice la nación y el
editorial de clarín bien en la nacional
destaca que también brenda uliarte
también mintió a sus amigos con los que
se encontró después del ataque les dijo
que hacía también tiempo que no sabía
nada de su pareja y que estos amigos
fueron a declarar voluntariamente ante
la policía tras digamos la detención de
la señora uliarte y el clarín el
clariano finalmente destaca en la
opinión del editor digital ricardo roa
que finalmente admite que el ataque fue
lo que pareció digamos pero sin embargo
culpabiliza en cierto modo a la
vicepresidenta dije que dice que fue su
ego lo que la llevó a estar desprotegida
voluntariamente lo que permitió a lícito
literalmente un chiflado lunático o como
se le quiera llamar pues que llegara a
centímetros de la vicepresidenta y que
acabara de dispararle también dice que
él pues venía de hacerse un tatuaje
medio nazi bueno me dio totalmente nazi
ya esto ya y muy rápidamente terminemos
en brasil que celebra sus 200 años de
independencia sí y destaca hoy el país
la figura de ricardo es tucker que es la
sombra de la favorito a las elecciones
presidenciales de este octubre luis
ignacio lula da silva y él es su
fotógrafo desde que llegó al poder hace
20 años y aquí destaca algunas de las
imágenes no más destacadas que ha tomado
es tucker de lula da silva entre otras
cosas señala el país viajaron juntos por
todo el mundo pero las fotos más
recordadas las tomó en brásil entre
ellas las que muestran a lula en
volandas sobre un mar de seguidores
justo antes de entrar y salir de prisión
tomadas en el sindicato de los
metalúrgicos donde lula nació y se
consolidó como político no imágenes que
es también ahora mismo se están usando
de cara a esta campaña presidencial
gracias rosa por esta ronda por la
prensa latinoamericana nosotros
continuamos con nuestro primer mitad o
del día